so um yeah this is s topic I set mon why
takes care business um GTA 6 dropped
this y'all dropped this week man
absolutely insane trailer right that
broke the internet the views I can't
even keep up with at this point as far
18 million views that's crazy on YouTube
channel um biggest YouTube debut ever
you know 93 million views over its first
24 hours oh man over 123 at press
time insane a lot of commentary here and
uh yeah I mean you know where can we
stop besides the the the the breaking of
every record Shadow you know we got to
talk about the game itself and this is I
believe s's beloved rock star so you're
back um your thoughts this is your topic
where you at with it yeah man I mean GTA
5 launched in 2012 wow there tail end of
the Xbox 360 PS3 generation the start of
the the wiii U generation if you want to
call it that the Generation Um that's
how far back this game goes
and the fact that you know I've always
felt that things nobody one UPS Rockstar
but Rockstar nobody can't nobody put
puts in the time the resources to make a
game and have them talk about it release
it when they think it's ready and there
there's no other metric other than when
it's ready you'll get it yep and however
long it takes for that game to be ready
if this game comes out in
2025 we are looking at a game that is 13
years in the
make it's just insane like
um I was super impressed the thing about
Rockstar also is that when you have
these these trailers and they break them
down afterwards you realize oh this is
not they're not showing you the vertical
slice they're not showing you what the
you know what they hope the game will be
they're showing you the game they're
showing you the game whether it be in
cinematics which are usually in the
real-time engine which is the rage
engine right an engine that they created
and have been refining over years and
multiple games including the the Red
Dead franchise
um when you look at this game there's
pretty much nothing that I've seen to
this point since GTA 5 compares to what
they're looking to do with GTA 6 and
going back to Vice City um well not Vice
City we're going back to the to
essentially Florida right with the state
of leonida is what they're calling
Florida leonida and obviously Vice City
will be included within the state of
leonit um the level of detail that I saw
in this trailer is just mindboggling to
me really when you think about you know
these consoles are powerful mhm when you
think about what they're trying to do
here in terms of what I think they're
trying to do is terms of density right
yeah density and scale they're doing
both I feel um when you you know look at
the flamingos flying out and you see
like a thousand flamingos and and then
in Red Dead you saw like you know
whatever 50 of them whatever the case
may be you see the leaps in technology
you see what they're trying to do um and
again it's one of those things where you
can't help but you know be Gob smacked
because you know that's the game right
you know that they're not trying to fool
you you know that this is this is the
game um so again I was super impressed I
was you know again I was sad for the
team that they didn't have their moment
the way they should have had it yeah but
at the end of the day the end result is
still the same the internet went crazy
for it the world went crazy for it um
and guys you know we next year well not
next year the year after next okay we
will have at some point people breathe a
s of relief that day yeah exactly
2024 because this is the game that
everybody gets out of the way of you you
just don't you don't play with this you
don't play it with GTA um what did you
guys think because again I'm I'm a big
I'm a Rockstar fan yeah Red Dead would
you say that sh your number one Studio
who who would be your top three Studios
man never ask I got it it's
Rockstar
Arcane and I love baseball so it's got
to be Sony San
die yeah but like um yeah Rockstar
really is again because I there's no I
remember playing the original GTA's the
top W top down wow on PlayStation one
right because again PlayStation one you
guys know everything under the sun came
out in that game there was so many wacky
and quirky games and you see this you
like oh wow they're really trying to do
this this this murder simulation or
whatever and you know obviously it's
it's it's it's down it's cartoonish but
you see what they're getting at and then
you make the jump to the PlayStation 2
and three when three came out I was like
oh they just they realizing the the same
vision in 3D um and they got it right
and I remember playing this and I like
is this really as good as I think it is
and again you go back to it now and it's
of a time and it doesn't hold up as well
but the essence of what they were trying
to do and how important that game that
that game is to the history of game you
cannot deny that
so um yeah they really to me Rockstar
signifies just that they're rock stars
and they really they're get their their
goal and their aim every time they come
out is to raise the bar in a way that no
one else can touch people can look up at
it be like wow this is amazing how you
know what what can we glean from this to
add to our open world but no one's gonna
have the budget no one is going to put
the time the effort um to really do the
things that Rockstar does in their game
so again it's that's why every time a
rockstar game releases it's a moment
right it it really is a special moment
and at this rate they don't release a
whole lot of games so you know you get
one every decade like you know it's
funny because in the I don't know if you
guys noticed that in the the comment
section of the of the the video up on
Rockstar site there were people
literally said talk about shout out to
the homies that didn't make it to the to
to the trailer the homies that you know
were here 10 years ago yeah was one of
those things where they're paying homage
to their friends that weren't here to
witness the
GTA because it's a decade in the
making it's kind of Bonkers that this is
uh but this is what they do I mean this
and this is this is the core game we're
talking about yes we're not even talking
about GTA online gt online is a whole
another thing be we don't know how they
going to handle that are they is this
GTA online going to be attached to this
or is this the single player game and
we'll get GTA
onlineer right and just attaching it to
to present GTA online War because they
they upgraded right they upgraded GTA
online to to be more inline I guess they
up the upgrade was technically on the
Xbox One PS4 generation to upgrade and
that's what they've been using moving
forward now if I'm not mistaken maybe
I'm wrong about that I don't play GTA
online
um so maybe that is the case and they to
that or is it going to be its own thing
or are they going to do the crazy thing
which I don't know I don't think they'll
do is is rebuild the whole thing for the
gr for GTA 6 who knows I have no idea
but um we're going to see at least this
game is they're gonna sell us this
version of the game they going to sell
us a PC version of the game at some
point PC no no announcement on PC at
large no announcement on PC if if that
next Nintendo console could run it in
any way shape that's reasonable it will
will be on that platform and then of
course we'll get a next gen upgrade or
or whatever re-release of this game
they're going to sell us this game
multiple times they're going to make
billions upon billions of dollars and
people will be happy giving it to them
because they know that it's GTA 6 yeah
so um and you know capping for a game
before is out is one of those things but
I'm like they don't they don't really
miss in my book I know you guys aren't
red dead guys but in my book they don't
miss no Red Dead is fine we can't just
not for everybody
but
understand dispute the quality horse
Bulls yeah when you know they pay
attention to that it's real shut you
stupid adct man GTA 6 your thoughts the
trailer what what was you thinking when
you saw this thing I mean it it
definitely uh I'm looking forward to
playing it like as far as like everyone
else like I've always saw like up until
five I saw GTA as like a really fun game
that I really enjoy playing uh because
of you know you all the support they've
done from like the GTA 4 franchise but I
I ain't going to lie like after I played
GTA 5 and I expected like more support
when it comes to like the single player
narrative and they never done it and
they just focused on the online
infrastructure it's just like it's I I'm
not as hyped for it anymore look I'm
gonna play it and I think it's gonna
definitely be the biggest game that's
came out in a long long long time for
the foreseeable future but it's just
like it's something I'm gonna play one
time and probably never touch again
because it's like I don't like that
multiplayer stuff I don't like my
brother he GNA probably put like a
thousand plus hours into it but it's
just like I'm gonna play that campaign
one time oh the campaign you play yeah
yeah maybe twice depending if they do
some things you know where it's like
some form of repay ability but I ain't
GNA lie like at GTA online kind of
killed my hype for GTA franchise going
forward because I know out the gate
they're going to put a lot of that
there's a lot of budgeting going into
that single player
but I know after that initial single
player is out that's it unless you like
the multiplayer it's a rat yeah and I'm
going to enjoy playing the single player
don't get me wrong but it's just as far
as like being really really excited for
it you it'll come out and I'll play it
definitely it'll be probably you know
I'd be really hyped to play it but I
know that they're not going to most
likely do anything with that single
player after the actual game comes out
so were you impressed did you at least
like what youself this is what my
question it look cool I I I feel like I
need I miss happy addict I don't feel
like a happy addict lately I'm just I'm
just I don't Happ it just it doesn't I I
get it you guys are are are excited and
that that's cool you
guys he said I get it that you dudes
like that but this is no it's not about
not liking like I play I I beat GTA 5 I
enjoy playing GTA wait say that again
say that word you enjoyed I I played
that day one you know I sat in the the
long giant line that was there and
what's funny it's just
like I expected more from that campaign
I expected to build off for Franklin
Michael and Trevor and I never got it so
it was just like so you want me to put
more time investment into another game
with two more characters knowing that
nothing after that happens because to me
but you did enjoy what you first played
you did enjoy no I I enjoyed it I enjoy
I like when you enjoy but I I just don't
to me if if you in order to really
truly enjoy the the the experience of of
GTA 5 you got to get on that multiplayer
and it's just I did not true how how
many people here can how many people
here can also say they did you guys play
GTA 5 when it came back to the Xbox one
did you rebeat it no h don't know
because it had no value outside of that
single player experience like yeah the
multiplayer is where they at they are
they outside that J I definitely agree
with you there that's for sure no doubt
no doubt um that was it I'm sorry cut
you off yeah yeah yeah I'm good no doubt
no doubt I mean I want people I see
people look I'm going to play the game
like he my thing like I'm not sitting
here doing jumping jack slapping my
thigh dip down hit us with the line he
said I'm happy that you're happy you hit
us with that I'm happy that you're happy
I'm excited you guys are happy and I'm
going to be right there with you but I
know in my
that that excitement's going to last for
like two three days because that
multiplayer and who knows maybe they'll
hit me with the multiplayer I don't know
but my my brother is obsessed took over
his life yeah see and I'm excited for
people like him that love that
multiplayer thing it's just like as far
as me I'm excited to get my hands on
that campaign because I know Rockstar
does crazy stuff with their games and
they're going to evolve that you know
that type of game like like immersively
but like to me too I don't want I played
uh when I played GTA 5 I played Red Dead
2 I am not feeling the the clunkiness of
the of the player and I feel like
they're not going to fix that you know I
get people are like it's realistic you
can't stop on a d that's cool it's a
game though if I wanted to do that i' go
out there and jog with the control I got
you I got you you need to see true
gameplay system improvements from do
y'all remember the argument I had with
adct with r dead yes I remember oh my
God years ago now at this point yes he
was not about that he not about I'm not
saying that you guys don't have the
right to enjoy it but it's just like I'm
not there that's like oh my God it's a
2025 I can't wait you know poing bottles
you D popping bottles you like yo that
looks cool you know what's funny is it
was when it dropped I didn't even watch
it I went in there and got my brother
and me and him both watching
so it's just like it's cool I'm going to
enjoy playing it I just like you enjoy
St there is way more games that I'm
looking forward to over GTA 6 for
instance Final Fantasy rebirth I'm
looking more forward to that you excited
because that's coming out sooner or
because mainly coming out soon here's
the thing like a lot it's mainly just I
know I'm not going to enjoy the entire
the entir package of GTA 6 that's and
it's just the campaign I'm going to
enjoy you know I i' bought that game
twice and I and I only really played it
once like and I enjoy playing it I do
but I think like the GTA thing with me
went out the floor the old days where
you know you could just spawn jets in
front of you and stuff like it's just
like after that it's still a phenomenal
game in Rockstar is definitely top five
developers in the industry but it's I'm
not going out and saying that it's like
the most hype game that's ever coming
out I hope you guys enjoy it I'm enjoy
it with you but I'm not I'm not going to
trick myself and hyping myself up for
for a year and a half to two to play
something for two days and just drop it
because I know that's what's going to
happen that's fair you know where you at
with it you know where you at with I
just like bothering you continue
on King look King your thoughts uh GTA
Florida in the building where we at um
the one game that
can uh Dodge the criticism and the
softness of what's going on that we have
with uh the individuals that are vocal
nowadays you know sensitive dudes softb
jelly back dudes back okay for that
that's ain't for them grant that photo
didn't care about y'all like gr Grand
Theft Auto went out there to offend you
to put um culture in your face and it's
always been topical like Grand Theft a
has always been like an encapsulation of
whatever time is going on I um San
Andreas for me was a peak cuz I'm not
from that was the peak for me too San
Andreas that was the peak for me too no
I didn't say it was the peak I said it
was a peak for me into um La culture oh
PE like look yeah because what what I
saw was I learned from I I learned La
culture from Colors the movie um boys in
the hood you know stuff like that and it
was always like the negative stuff not
saying that the Grand Theft Auto didn't
have like some negative connotation to
it but it it was still you know CJ was
dope going around the neighborhood when
I got to Cali the first thing I thought
was wow Grand Theft Auto San Andreas
prepared me for this like all the houses
like look like in the game like and I
was like yo I said this is really dope
um I know is going to be a a year from
now so it's so many games that's coming
out ahead of time I can't really say
that my um excitement for it is super
high right because I have to wait and
there's a lot of stuff that's coming out
before then but I know the day that it
comes out day and date I'm going to be
playing it I'm GNA finish the story I
never got into the online aspect of it
and the online aspect of it is as robust
as fortnite yeah like they they make
their money off I forgot what their
currency is called
shark is the Shark cards I don't know
what the actual currency is maybe it's
just called Shark currency I don't know
right but like what adct was saying I
understand they was not dropping any um
story driven stuff right the stuff that
we got for uh Vice City like the ballet
the Gay Tony and stuff like that that
stuff was cool they didn't do that with
five yeah good point and what they did
do though I saw them dropping story
content for the online
remember they had like this Heist thing
and all all types of stuff was around
the online and I'm like how how robust
is this so I think now they learned a
lesson from five that the online was
separate from the story and I think
they're going to do it in a fashion that
the online because now we're online
alwayss right now I think they're going
to do the online and the story in a way
that is to together and adct is going to
get that story content that's going to
be driven towards the online I think
Grand Theft Auto 6 is always online the
story is built and wrapped around the
online and it's one big giant package
and instead of two separate packages oh
don't say that people gonna be really
upset if it's that they they they
shouldn't be because it should be a way
for you to play it in a way that you
don't have to worry about you know
somebody putting a bounty on your head
and stuff like that but I think the game
is going to be dope I I definitely
sort
graphically out of this world wow and
the first thing you heard these monkey
mouth dudes saying monkey dud was the
first hurdle for a Grand Theft
46 is little man oh wow I didn't even
know about when Boulders gate showed
you Boulders Gate 3 showed you
little man is leading the
charge stop with the rhetoric bro your
unstable
box is the problem that's why youall
need a pro so hopefully that Pro come
out right before that joint come out to
get your frames up because your frames
is looking a little weak right now but
yeah y I will always stay on the head
pause you know you mentioned that and
it's funny because most people are
speculating this game is a 30 FPS game
right yeah y yeah well because what
happens is this is what always happens
right you start getting to a point in
generation you start getting the things
that you want out of the generation
especially the hardcore right what we
we're obviously the bells and whistles
the prettiness the resolution that's
great but we want performance
everybody's used to that 60 FPS we want
that now that in comes a game like this
that pushes the boundaries right 30 bro
30 right I see that's 30 so if it is
true that we aren't we just getting a a
refresh of the Xbox uh consoles right
tent of the pro could be the 60 frames
definitive and this is the thing for on
the PlayStation side right if if like
King said if that coincides could have a
little bit of a cool there because
there's no PC version right so at least
they haven't talked about it yet and and
they knowing Rockstar they know they can
sell you this game again they're gonna
wait they're G to wait and it's going to
be at least a year after whatever this
game releases that they're going to give
the PC version uh it could be like if
that if that coincides all of a sudden
this looks more you know playst
Centric if you want to say that I'm
going tell you this right now only
console that could run 60 at the highest
Fidelity I will be playing it on that
console if that is the case a lot of
I'mma say
this whoever gets the market and wins I
don't care what it runs like on your
machine yeah if XBox gets that marketing
and you can put Call of Duty on the
sticker on the box with uh Grand Theft
Auto and star oh wow and B this gate and
Game Pass at that same time you might as
well take that PlayStation up wrap it up
with a doobie and Chuck it in the bushes
because y' your death will be in 2025
that will be it so you better hope Jim
put some stimulus package away to get
that grand theft 406 because if y'all
don't get that
marketing G is at a point I don't think
they they could just be like F both of
y'all yeah they don't even need they're
like we're it's free money it's free
money bro true but who who got enough
bag for that for that Microsoft dude
they just spent 70 true all right you
know who don't got enough money for it
all right fair enough but we and what
does marketing entail enta right what
does it mean when we talk about it like
you see how these dudes said blade and
is um on Xbox right and dudes is like
did they say it on Xbox I don't know
well now when they say Grand Theft Auto
6 is on Xbox oh you guys going to be
like oh snap he said it they putting the
foot on their
neck yo here that's what we went to
Market it for just for you soft jelly
back dud in this unlikely
[Music]
scenario okay we'll see we'll see I
don't know what's going happen I've been
right yeah yeah he has been he has been
I mean look I'll jump in if you was
finish what I'm done yeah now look um
got to give solest props man Rockstar
man crazy levels to this there is levels
to this like it is stunning how it looks
it is the the she you know why he got
that face why he got that face cuz he
know that Tech is going to be putting
that Red Dead Redemption for
sure or the Remake the Remake yeah you
know what it is you know what it is the
confidence in them is because when they
show you this they don't have like I
said they don't have a need to show you
the vertical slight M they're showing
you the game and then you let the
digital Foundry go in and break it down
like oh this this much of this much of
it is like real time like this could be
gameplay this could be a cut scene where
they smooth it out a little bit but all
it's all ingame engine and some of it is
straight up gameplay they never lie to
you they never lie to you anything that
you I saw that beach scene you know oh
my God all the density of the people the
detail you saw the chunky the thick
girls with the
tattoos in the back oh shout out to the
twerk God bless they out here doing the
Lord's work
rockar work physics you out here doing
the Lord's work that each and every Dev
developer who worked hard who worked
hard on this clearly shout out to a very
clearly very clear they very hard they
got the horse balls team on the man they
out here doing the Lord's work and look
that you know what's funny is like the
people attacking them for doing it it's
like in case you ain't noticed GTA is
supposed to be a parody of America and
that's what it's it's common for them
it's like look like I don't and then you
got like an adjacent people saying like
they they've gone woke too and it's like
what do you mean a female protagonist
people are just throwing that everywhere
it's like look bde I don't B B I don't
think Lucia oh Lucia yes yes yes put
that mask on let's go get that work
here's the thing the adct said it
perfectly the reason why I love Rockstar
when it comes to G even though I am not
a GTA dude like they like adct I was
teasing them because I'm the same way
what it is their world are so immersive
of I end up not doing the main story and
just getting
distracted yeah I just freeze up I I'm
I'm so overwhelmed with all the systems
and the beauty that's going on you could
literally do side games and be immersed
in these things forever but the beauty
of CJ was de remember he was bring he
definitely get
his facts I remember that so the thing
is where adct is right is I
love and King what you're saying their
creative expression to say you can't
tell us how to make our games we are
going to take the creative expression
and the freedom to give a snapshot of
what we feel the world is right now and
what I love about them is they take from
real media kind of events that has
happened this is the most Florida game y
I have ever seen and what's funny is is
a lot of King all all the Lords know you
know I got a lot of cnergy to Florida
recently so it's like seeing it I'm like
yep that's it and every group gets to
smoke every group gets to smoke it don't
matter what your ethnicity your
background where yall from everybody
gets to smoke in the most You Know
parody way but it's accurate cuz you
like yo someone had a a a a new shot of
every thing that they took from real
even from the guy pulling the crocodile
out know somebody had the city girls
fever what was they made record they had
that record I forgot what that record
was hot girl summer yeah hot girl
whatever they had like everybody's
getting and then you know shout out my
Backwoods my you know cauas like y
everyone's getting it so I like I love
the fact that they are consistent on
their message every GTA and this is why
people love it this is why the millions
the billions go for this game is one of
the most controversial games from the
violence and from the depiction
standpoint but this is why I love devs
allowed to do their Vision how they do
it and the people speak cuz this to
King's Point about like how maybe he not
be satisfied with MCU or certain things
with messages agenda they are going to
make this game the way they want to make
it and they're getting rewarded because
the people agree this is what's up but
I'll let yall jump I want to jump jump I
just wanted to say that is so dopee that
they said you going to buy this anyway
yes oh yeah it don't matter this that's
the thing and like you said it's immune
to all of this there some of this
conversation has been going on online
about to addex point the wokeness or
whatever right some people saying like
oh you know all of that Florida man
stuff all that stuff is like oh that's
not what Florida is right now and people
started talking about the politics of
stuff of like oh you know Florida really
is like in a in a crazy state right now
where you know they they're blocking
immigrants trying to kick out nature you
why don't you have why when did people
stop having fun and stop like I I've
always been of the mind that stereotypes
exist because they're they're this close
to reality right it could be an
exaggeration but it's they're this close
to reality and to me GTA games always
remind me that we need to laugh at
ourselves and look in the mirror and
laugh at ourselves sometimes and not
take ourselves so Ser it's a Time piece
what's going really it always it's a
snapshot snapshot and and it's their
exaggeration of that snapshot that time
right and at the same time you will
always find within that something with
cultural relevance today they're NE
these guys are very smart they spend
years and years and years building this
out to give you something that is a
sarcastic yes twerking on a car was
crazy EXA exactly take on what and the
funny thing about it is that the heads
of the the heads of this are are British
guys right so it's like it's the BR take
on what how they look at America on some
levels right that is it would be like
silver server coming to Earth oh this is
what y'all be doing oh this what y doing
exactly oh n like let's let's let's have
fun let's stop and not be so serious and
I interrup I was going to jump in real
quick have you guys seen the um the
Bingo cars things people have been doing
recently like at an event they'll have
like a bingo card they'll have like
guesses what they think is going to be
at the event and the and the goal is to
like do it like you would actually try
to win Bingo where it's like straight
line or straight down I bet you Rockstar
has a bingo card on
woke not not Florida like just they got
like they're all in this this giant
Bingo on the wall it's like no I've seen
that I've seen that bring it up prove
it I guarantee you all of that stuff
you're gonna find some missions in there
address all that stuff in a funny way
that you should look at and laugh at to
see how stupid human being I saw
Rockstar is the type of person to make a
mission about a a company trying to
control another company and it's quote
unquote
wokeness what what what I saw in
Spider-Man it was a side mission where
um miles had to help a student uh talk
to somebody for homec yep I remember
right and I
saw people refused to do that mission oh
wow because they were either against a
certain uh
demographic I know what you're talking
or they had certain insecurities within
their sell yep right and this is what I
said this is a video
game right I don't care I there's no
stance to have like this is not real
characters this is not real stuff
happening um how are you offended like
how are you offend it and and then if
you don't do that mission because that's
the last mission you don't get the
suit it's a suit unlocked after that so
it's dudes that's running around there
with half a game because in their head
they're offended yeah if you are
offended and you put up that woke crap
talking about oh Grand Theft is woke I
don't like twerking on cars I didn't
like how they depicted the black people
I didn't like how they had the bik girl
over there with the cam and stuff we
should not be laughing you need to go
away yeah don't don't don't be offended
for me please yeah just I just my 70
going to be
lit look it's just it's just not for you
that's just how I look you know what's
funny I I think after hogwart's Legacy
people on the internet need to realize
if you push too much it's going to back
Tri the opposite and and now look at the
views look look at the reaction the
gamers are saying this is what we want
we don't want certain other things and
it's a direct reflection of that yeah
they like stop trying to do that in our
medium and it's a it's a it's a it's a
pushback I agree you know what's sad you
know what's sad the ballot of Gay Tony
couldn't be named that yes I remember
that you're right it couldn't be named
couldn't be named that now we didn't
think nothing of it back then of it yeah
brought it yeah I love that DLC yeah it
was dope it was fire so the the thought
process with how far we have fallen at
as a people in a short period of time
yeah that's crazy I don't even want to
hear y listen my $7 is lit like lit and
if they ask me for hundred I'll still
stop stop stop stop
do and they going clip your using but I
will say like again you know I'm always
about creative expression and and
allowing the devs to create the vision
they want however they want to want and
the cops agree so we going move on
un last shout out shout out to Florida
Joker trying to get his bag it a happen
crazy it a ask Lindsay Lohan it ain't
happening it ain't happening he was like
they ripped me off get out of here out
you're done se he doesn't have a big he
doesn't have a big enough bank account
to take them to court if you're lucky
they might give you a copy of the game
be happy with that be happy with that